I got Wellfleet Chatham most of Falmouth
half a New Bedford my cousin down in
Quincy my guy of the Marblehead we can
get Framingham that's just 15 pounds a
week
[Music]
take first back
[Music]
they want more they want more
more
[Applause]
[Music]
you spending the summer with auntie Bob
sending me away for the summer what a
cliche yeah wait no okay okay
[Music]
[Music]
can you take me home
look she gave me man okay hey yourself
hope you show up guess who got lucky I
can't get around my mind
[Music]
what would you say if I told you I
wanted to start so we what's this one
that's a zip more people plot these my
life will be a lot easier we should sell
more of those the problem is dealing
dime bags teenagers we need customers
who buy in bulk you didn't know how to
use a bomb
and now you're trying to tell me how to
flip week I have something you've been
looking for you know you're not cops
gosh a good question the cops can't do
that
sit down give me more money to be the
rest I've ever seen anything shady right
Daisy sweetheart
play something celebratory
happens every song Munir so heavy
campaign
the night's turn long sleepless when you
are cooler times you know what it is
it's gonna tear you about can't hold on
everything I think some things yeah then
I hope you're good at being her
[Music]
you